Il y a quelques jours, vous avez franchi
la barre des 500 000 abonnés sur YouTube.
C'est énorme !
Jamais je n'ai pensé que ça irait aussi vite.
Un grand merci donc à vous toutes et tous
qui m'accompagnez dans cette aventure et m'encouragez avec vos messages et vos commentaires.
Pour fêter ça, j'ai donc décidé de réaliser une vidéo FAQ.
Alors j'ai pris un énorme plaisir à vous lire.
J'espère que les réponses seront à la hauteur.
On va passer dans l'atelier. Place à vos questions.
Allez, c'est parti !
Eh bien quand j'étais petit, enfin petit...
Ça a commencé à l'âge de 10-12 ans,
je voulais devenir journaliste.
J'allais en colonie de vacances et
en colonie de vacances, il fallait faire un journal.
Eh bien, on le faisait à tour de rôle,
mais j'adorais cet exercice
et j'étais prêt à échanger cette corvée contre d'autres :
faire la vaisselle par exemple
ou nettoyer le campement.
J'adorais raconter des histoires, j'adorais écrire
et un jour je me suis dit
ce serait merveilleux d'en faire mon métier.
J'ai cette chance de pouvoir vous raconter des histoires.
Non ! C''est extrêmement triste...
Évidemment que oui !
Je m'amuse d'abord quand je l'écris.
Je prends plaisir à apprendre
donc ça c'est le premier effet kiss cool.
Ensuite, je prends plaisir
et je m'amuse à le mettre en scène.
Avec la petite caméra, quand on imagine les maquettes,
quand on trouve les objets que l'on va détourner
pour faire une maquette
et vous imaginez bien aussi que
pendant les tournages on s'amuse beaucoup.
Surtout quand on est obligé de reprendre
une vidéo dix fois parce que ma langue a fourché.
et que je n'y arrive pas...
Les cubes n'étaient pas "toutàlafai"...
toutàlafai" pleins
Des pains de glace qui sont ensuite déb "blablabla"
"Blablabla"
"Soltibla"
Moi ça me fait moins rire,
mais la petite caméra, ça l'amuse beaucoup.
Eh bien derrière cette caméra,
il y a Manuela, c'est mon épouse.
Ce projet a vu le jour pendant le confinement,
et pendant le confinement, nous n'étions que deux ici
dans cet atelier et dans le jardin.
Alors Manuela s'occupe de l'image
mais également du son.
Et elle est douée. Je peux même pas vous la
présenter, puisque là, en ce moment,
elle est derrière la caméra
avec le casque sur les oreilles.
Évidemment ! Vous savez j'adore les volcans
et j'ai hâte d'aller arpenter la chaine des Puys,
avec la petite caméra,
pour vous raconter leur formation.
Alors, je suis journaliste à la base.
Pour préparer ces vidéos, j'utilise tous les moyens qu'utilisent traditionnellement les journalistes.
Les livres. J'en ai pas mal au-dessus de ma tête.
Une bibliothèque, dans laquelle on trouve
énormément de livres de sciences, de pédagogie.
Et puis, j'utilise aussi les journaux,
les magazines que je lis régulièrement.
J'écoute aussi beaucoup la radio, pas mal
de podcasts autour des sujets scientifiques
Et puis les sites internet évidemment,
qui traitent des sujets que j'aborde dans mes vidéos.
L' essentiel, c'est de croiser les informations.Quand je lis quelque chose quelque part, que j'ai un petit doute,
et bien j'essaie de retrouver cette information expliquée, confirmée par une autre source.
Ça, c'est mon boulot de journaliste...
Alors, c'est difficile de conseiller un livre,
un roman, un essai...
Si c'est pour les vacances,
oui j'ai un livre à vous conseiller, un livre que j'ai adoré :
Magellan de Stefan Zweig qui raconte
l'épopée du navigateur au XVIème siècle
le premier navigateur à avoir fait le tour du Monde.
Voilà ! C'est le premier à avoir imaginé qu'entre l'Europe
et l'Asie, il y avait un continent : l'Amérique.
Je rappelle que lorsque Christophe Colomb
découvre l'Amérique,
Il pense que c'est l'Inde.
C'est une magnifique histoire et le lire pendant
les vacances, c'est vraiment le moment idéal.
Alors oui... Il y a aussi des experts.
J'en ai une liste longue comme mon bras.
Depuis une trentaine d'années,
dès que je veux vérifier quelque chose,
et ça m'arrive très très souvent, je consulte ces experts.
Même lorsque j'explique quelque chose
que j'ai déjà expliqué auparavant,
je veux m'assurer que ça n'a pas changé
parce que la science évolue
même lorsqu'on explique des principes de base.
Je vais vous faire une confidence :
je suis nul en bricolage !
C'est Manuela qui les fabrique.
On les conçoit ensemble,
on conçoit les maquettes, les décors...
Souvent je fais des petits croquis
et Manuela les fabrique ensuite.
Alors pour ça elle utilise des objets
que nous avons autour de nous
et très souvent d'ailleurs elle détourne les objets.
Au début, c'était un peu une obligation,
parce que pendant le confinement,
tous les magasins où nous aurions pu
nous approvisionner étaient fermés.
Donc, il fallait trouver d'autres solutions.
Ce saladier, par exemple,
a été transformé en demi globe.
et je suis sûr qu'avec ses talents,
elle aurait pu aussi le transformer en casque.
Le corps de la fusée a été réalisé à partir
d'une boîte d'amuse-gueule : des Pringles.
Et si vous regardez bien, vous voyez
sous la peinture bleue un petit peu de rose.
Tout simplement parce que, avant d'être une fusée,
cette boîte de Pringles a été une trachée
qui m'a servi à expliquer comment fonctionnaient
les cordes vocales.
Au-dessus, voilà...L'étage supérieur a été réalisé
à partir d'une petite burette d'huile
qui appartenait à mon grand-père.
Vous voyez, on recycle aussi pas mal
quand on fait des maquettes.
He bien, ce livre est en cours d'écriture.
J'en suis à peu près à la moitié.
Il devrait sortir au mois de novembre
et c'est un livre dans lequel je reprends tous les thèmes que j'ai abordé au cours des 55 jours de confinement.
alors on y retrouve les textes des capsules
mais aussi beaucoup de choses que je n'ai pas eu
le temps de vous dire à propos de ces sujets,
parce qu'en une minute,
je ne pouvais pas tout vous raconter.
Et puis, vous allez retrouver à l'intérieur
de ce livre des images, des dessins...
qui sont réalisés par la petite caméra,
où l'on retrouve tous les décors que nous avons utilisé
pour illustrer les phénomènes
que j'ai décrit à travers ces capsules
Non ! Ce n'est pas mon grand-père qui a inspiré Hergé pour créer le personnage du professeur Tournesol.
C'est le grand-père de Bertrand Piccard,
l'inventeur du Solar Impulse.
Vous savez, cet avion solaire
qui a fait le tour de la planète
Bertrand Piccard a également fait le
tour de la planète en ballon
et c'est son grand-père, Auguste Piccard,
qui a été le premier à monter
dans la stratosphère en ballon.
Quinze mille mètres d'altitude.
C'est ce scientifique qui a inspiré Hergé
un scientifique qui avait des lunettes rondes.
Non ! je n'y ai jamais pensé
parce que le métier d'enseignant est très différent.
c'est un métier complexe
Bien sûr, je transmets...
Tiens toi je vais te pousser,
j'en ai marre de heurter tes feuilles,
des frondes s'agissant des fougères...
Je suis un passeur, je suis entre ceux qui détiennent
le savoir et ceux qui veulent l'acquérir.
Un peu comme les enseignants,
mais je ne le fais pas du tout dans le même cadre.
Je le fais à travers un petit écran, sur des livres...
Une manière de vous divertir
sous forme de spectacles, de loisirs.
Alors qu'un enseignant, lui,
il est là pour aussi avoir des résultats.
Faire en sorte qu'après ses cours,
les choses soient rentrés dans nos petites têtes
et qu'on soit en mesure de répondre
aux questions qui seront posées
lors d'un exercice ou lors d'un examen.
Moi, je ne vous pose jamais de question.
Évidemment,
j'ai énormément de choses à vous raconter
sur ce qui se passe au-dessus de nos têtes,
sur nos étoiles, le soleil en particulier,
les trous noirs, etc, etc...
Il y a une actualité extrêmement riche dans ce domaine
et je compte bien vous en faire profiter !
Sans partir dans l'espace...
Alors évidemment, il y a toujours
des projets dans les tuyaux.
Mais pour le moment rien de concret
en ce qui concerne la télévision.
Il y aura donc toujours le Monde de Jamy.
En revanche, en ce qui concerne YouTube
pour le moment il y a "chez Jamy"
mais promis à partir de la rentrée
de nouveaux formats vont arriver
C'est encore un petit peu tôt pour vous en parler
Non mais ho !!!
C'est pas parce que j'ai de la barbe
blanche que je vais prendre ma retraite.
Je n'ai que 56 ans. Je fais du sport,
je fais attention à mon alimentation.
Je me porte très bien
et je compte bien vous raconter des histoires
pendant encore très très longtemps...
Pourquoi je continue ? Mais tout simplement
parce que ça me plait, ça m'amuse, ça m'épanouit.
Ce n'est pas un effort. Quand je me lève le matin,
je n'ai qu'une idée en tête,
c'est apprendre quelque chose, y prendre du plaisir
et ensuite faire en sorte que les autres
puissent aussi prendre du plaisir.
Donc tant que je prendrais du plaisir,
vous en prendrez aussi.
Et je n'ai pas l'intention de m'arrêter demain.
Evidemment ! Avec Fred, avec Sabine.Bien sûr,
on se voit beaucoup moins souvent qu'auparavant,
on ne travaille plus ensemble depuis maintenant 7 ans.
Chacun a continué de son côté :
Fred a créé son site, sa chaîne
sur YouTube : "l'Esprit sorcier",
Sabine, elle est toujours journaliste.
Elle fait des spectacles autour du fonctionnement
des orchestres symphoniques,
des orchestres de chambre...
Mais régulièrement, on s'appelle
pour prendre des nouvelles des uns et des autres
et comme on est souvent aussi par monts et par vaux,
c'est vrai que c'est un peu difficile de se croiser.
Mais, régulièrement, on s'appelle.
En principe, à partir du mois de septembre.
On s'est octroyé avec la petite caméra
un petit peu de repos...
Donc une vidéo tous les quinze jours.
Mais à partir de début septembre,
on devrait reprendre notre rythme hebdomadaire.
Mieux que ça... Dans les semaines qui vont suivre,
il devrait aussi avoir de nouveaux formats sur YouTube.
J'espère que vous patienterez jusque-là !
Il me semble que le prochain Monde de Jamy
sera consacré aux inondations.
Il sera diffusé vraisemblablement à la rentrée,
entre le mois de septembre
et le mois de novembre.
Je ne peux pas vous en dire plus.
C'est une super émission avec des
effets spéciaux assez spectaculaires.
On a également une émission
sur les incendies de forêts.
Elle est quasiment terminée.
Une autre sur le langage des animaux.
Alors, c'est extraordinaire aussi.
J'ai eu la chance de plonger avec des dauphins.
Attention pas n'importe quelle plongée,
pas une plongée agressive.
Je me suis immergé dans l'eau, avec des experts
et j'ai laissé les dauphins venir vers moi.
C'est eux qui ont décidé et non pas moi
et je me suis retrouvé
au milieu d'un brouhaha à plusieurs reprises.
J'ai fais une dizaine de plongées.
C'est complètement dingue de se sentir
observé, scanné par les dauphins.
Et puis on a d'autres sujets en préparation.
Il ya quelques jours, vous m'avez peut-être vu
accroché à la paroi de l'Aiguille du Midi à Chamonix.
Ça, c'est une émission qui sera consacrée
à la montagne face au réchauffement.
Vous voyez ça donne envie !
Soyez curieux, posez-vous des questions.
Quand vous voyez quelque chose,
interrogez-vous, allez chercher la réponse.
Quand vous aurez la réponse
faites en sorte de la concevoir, de bien la comprendre.
Et vous verrez que, comprendre le monde
qui nous entoure est extrêmement épanouissant.
Vous voyez j'ai quelques objets autour de moi...
Comment cette plante, une fougère,
qui n'a pas de fleur, se reproduit ?
Eh bien ça nous permet de plonger
dans l'histoire du temps,
dans l'histoire de la végétation,
puisque les fougères figurent parmi les premières plantes qui ont colonisé notre planète.
Elles se reproduisent avec de tout
petits corpuscules qu'on appelle des spores.
Il n'y a pas de fleur avec cette plante.
C'est avant les fleurs.
Donc vous voyez, cette simple plante nous permet
de faire un bond dans le temps extraordinaire.
Avec ce caillou, ce caillou c'est une roche volcanique c'est ce qu'on appelle une bombe.
Eh bien pour savoir comment il s'est formé
pour savoir d'où il vient,
on rentre aussi dans l'histoire de notre planète.
Et puis cette fusée qui n'est qu'une maquette,
eh bien dès l'instant où on se pose la question
sur la manière dont elle s'arrache du sol,
on comprend certaines lois de la physique.
Et puis, quand on comprend comment une capsule
peut être mise en orbite autour de notre planète,
Comment la Station spatiale internationale
peut être mis en orbite,
comment un objet à 400 kilomètres au-dessus
de nos têtes tourne sans activer des moteurs.
Eh bien ce sont des lois de la physique
qui sont épanouissantes à comprendre.
Donc voilà ! Je vous conseille
de vous poser des questions
et d'avoir envie de comprendre
le monde qui nous entoure
Je vous promets que même dans les moments
qui sont les plus durs dans la vie
quand on s'accroche à des choses comme ça,
ce sont de vraies lumières, des phares,
qui nous invitent à continuer à aller encore plus loin !
C'est très sympa ! Bonnes vacances
à vous aussi...
et revenez en forme... Ciao !